how does Airbnb or platforms like that
because now they're not just their B&B
it's a very expanding and very
competitive space how does that play out
and I think in terms of the industry I
think you know it is not a zero-sum game
and that you know we in this case in the
hotel business really have to just
appreciate that you know again consumers
customers our customers are going to
want to access their in this case their
hotel solutions or their hospitality
solutions in the way that they want to
receive them so we're we again want to
make sure that from our brand value
proposition that we're able to offer
brand value proposition that meets our
customers needs so we're constantly
looking in terms of innovation and how
we can expand to meet that all still
within the context of Hilton our brands
our purpose and our vision and our
mission but then thinking about how that
means how we drive greater loyalty with
our customers so that they're really
part of being you know that we value
them deeply as Hilton customers and as
Hilton honors members and that that's
something that we we want to continue to
expand and also to provide greater
innovation in the way that we do that I
think there's so much to learn from
Airbnb and providers such as that and is
is really for me what's so exciting is
the platform you know so I mean look at
the Airbnb example or the loop of the
uber platform again these you know these
these platforms don't own taxis they
don't own he'll tell rooms but what they
do have is the platform and so think
about it from our platform and where
we're taking again tied directly to our
brand and that platform again would be
one that of course that would be digital
and it would manifest itself on a very
personal way I guess to you know
customer to to our service that we
provide them would you know they would
access it through their service that
they receive and you know that's how we
can drive greater loyalty being able to
do that
learning about the platform how they've
Newmont's the platform again to meet the
customer where the customer is of the
unit of one to have that all be self
accessible and then you know also
determined by again self through
technology that's very exciting so again
the innovation that we're looking at
particularly within of our guest rooms
is that you know this also would become
your digital wallet this becomes
everything that you would control in
your guest room this becomes everything
that you would do with that you need to
do within the hotel and ultimately what
we're looking for is that how all of
that would be integrated together so
that it would be seamless and
transparent to the guests experience as
they're moving from department to
department from leaving the hotel to
then checking in to go to their next
experience or to catch their next flight
all of that becomes a very much an
integrated experience that they're doing
and that has to do with the platforms
that are made available out there so the
the power of the platform I guess is
what would be my my greatest learning or
you know admiration and how can we learn
about that platform and then customer
data which i think is really the the
real important back-end of this is all
of that customer data that we then are
able to have in a very very positive way
again to customize our solutions for our
customers to better meet their needs and
then ultimately to be predictive so that
the predictive analytics that those
platforms are then providing with the
again with the many partners that we
work with to have integrated solutions
to have a seamless guest experience is
where I think it's all going and that's
really exciting
we have several internal solutions that
we do that we have on our learning
management systems platform in addition
we have other enhanced technology that
we can use to do that very much operate
like an app internally to be able to do
that and then we link that back to
social collaborative sites that we have
we have that again by by brands or by
hotels or by functions that we can do
that to use that you know to you
again these collaborative tools to
support that what's happened really you
know I would say you know as a major
shift from a guest perspective is how
you know this enabling technology is
able to and androids is able to enhance
the guest experience so in you know so
for our customers for our Hilton Honors
customers and we have millions of them
you know they're able to make their
entire reservations you know on through
their device they're then able to check
in on their device and we're in the
process now of enabling the entire
system about more than seven hundred and
forty five thousand guest rooms and over
in a hundred and four countries what
we're doing now is making the ability
for that for our guests to be able to go
straight to their room so what you'd be
able to do is you would be able to check
into your hotel you would then and what
I mean by checking you would announce to
the hotel I'm thinking of arriving at 3
o'clock and then it would say you know
it would Auto pick a hotel room for you
or it would allow you to pick your own
room
and based on your status you know it
would it would give you a show of rooms
that you could then pick from because
some customers want to be near the
elevators some customers don't want to
be near the elevator someone don't want
to be more than higher than the 6th
floor whatever it may be we can provide
those choices to them as Hilton honor
members and then the capability that's
being put in place many of them around
the world already have it enabled is
that directly on their device they would
be able to go straight to their room and
they would be able to just a green
circle goes on your iPhone or your
Android and then you just touch it and
and then the door blinks the little
green light blinks and then you hear a
click and that sound is like and that
light blinking flashing is like a thing
of beauty so in addition to that you
know so just think about that happening
so when you go down to the gym the same
thing happens when you if you had to get
into the elevator to Billiken available
you had to be able to use your key a
digital key would also just show up on
your device and if you're checking out
of the hotel and you valeted your car
and you're getting your car out you know
again your digital key would help you to
do that so again think of that from a
guest perspective and then weird we're
doing you know simultaneously we're
creating that entire experience for our
team members so that they can learn on
their devices and in many cases we do
that in a game of five-way so using
gamification to make that fun and
engaging bite-size little chunks to be
able to do that and then we want to
ensure that they've done that so there
has to be a degree of success or a
degree of completion you could say you
know think about that from a compliance
perspective but so that we know that
they know that they know it and that's
what we're looking for and again those
are all things that we measure those are
all things that we track and those are
all things that go to ensure that our
team members are able to provide great
guest experience because they're
competent and that they know what to do
you